[主播] 2022年6月19日，董宇辉完整直播回放。
[主播] 接下来就让我们隆重欢迎董老师上场，欢迎欢迎。
[嘉宾] 来了。
[主播] 来，欢迎董老师。
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 欢迎欢迎。
[主播] 休息好了吗，董老师？
[嘉宾] 对，我刚睡了一会儿。
[主播] 啊，那就好。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 我时常看着东东啊，顿顿啊，杰西啊，感慨命运的不公。
[主播] 就是 就是为什么人跟人的差异会这么大？
[主播] 好歹让我占一样啊。
[主播] 要么帅点。
[主播] 要么高点。
[主播] 最好呢就是又高又帅。
[主播] 没有办法。
[主播] 命运给了我一个比较难的模式，啊。
[主播] 晚上好啊，朋友们。
[主播] 为什么会弄个这个？这个是干嘛？
[嘉宾] 唱歌。
[主播] 唱歌的。
[主播] 谁要唱？
[嘉宾] 可以唱啊。
[主播] 啊，明白。
[主播] 有朋友说没休息好吗？因为我平时晚上不是睡眠一直比较差吗？
[主播] 然后最近一段时间呢，睡眠尤其差。
[主播] 所以白天我会在单位里休息一会儿。
[主播] 如果大家自己这个也有睡眠问题的话，你自己在天也睡会儿，好不好？
[主播] 中午吃完饭了，其实可以在那趴一会儿，不用每天来看东西，看时间长就烦了，我跟你说。
[主播] 如果一个东西你每天都接触啊，
[主播] 你可能就忘记它有多么美好了。
[主播] 真的。
[主播] 嗯，时间长了你都会 觉得习以为常，然后 不再珍惜的。
[主播] We all do that from time to time.
[主播] 人都是如此。
[主播] 一直在你身边的，
[主播] 你迟早都会厌烦。
[主播] 喜新厌旧就是符合人性的。
[主播] 所以你不要每天来。
[主播] 要不然你就不想听我说了。
[嘉宾] 有朋友说董宇辉上来开始擦桌子。
[主播] 这可能是一个当老师的习惯啊，因为我平时在当老师的时候，我桌子上放的都是书。
[主播] 我不是爱擦桌子，我只是不想让书脏。
[主播] 他自己在家里有时候懒也不擦桌子。
[主播] 我只是害怕把书弄脏了。
[主播] 你一个读书人把书都弄脏了。
[主播] 想象一下你是一个士兵，你的枪都生锈了。
[主播] 想象一下你个厨师，你连自己刀都不磨锋利一些。
[主播] 你不热爱自己的职业，嗯。
[嘉宾] 有朋友说一直以为董老师坐着播的。
[主播] 我是跪着播的。
[主播] 如果我站起来的话，大概有六米多高。
[主播] 为了影响，为了不影响大家的这个现实观感呢，
[主播] 我把腿锯了。
[主播] 现在是跪着播。
[主播] 对，这样让大家看的时候能稍微放松一些，啊。
[嘉宾] 来波福利吧，俞老师。
[主播] 来波福利，可以。
[主播] 来自山东的海盐，对吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 多少钱？
[嘉宾] 9块9。
[嘉宾] 一包。
[主播] 9块9七包。
[嘉宾] 5000单。
[嘉宾] 一号链接。
[主播] 我不知道你们你们家那块，冬天那个菜啊。
[主播] 冬天。
[主播] 就类似于泡菜。
[嘉宾] 东北酸菜。
[主播] 东北大酱，对吧？弄那个。
[嘉宾] 酸菜。
[主播] 酸菜，嗯。
[嘉宾] 东北不腌。
[主播] 以前可能你们物产丰富一些就其实还好，然后南方温度高一些，它冬天还有菜，其实就还好。
[主播] 北方的冬天啊，以前很漫长的。
[主播] 那会儿人们也没有好的东西吃。
[主播] 以前冬天是有自己腌制的菜的。
[主播] 大家在基本上接近霜降的时候，
[主播] 然后就会买很多的那个包菜啊，胡萝卜啊，等等一些的东西，甚至有青椒。
[主播] 洗干净。
[主播] 我记得每年那段时间都水，就温度开始很低了，水都开始冰凉冷手了的时候，
[主播] 每次我从学校回到家里，妈妈就这个很耐心的在洗。
[主播] 把那叶子洗得很干净。
[主播] 然后一片一片的洗干净。
[主播] 然后他要那个水也必须是烧热之后再放凉的那个凉白开。
[主播] 因为这样可能里头没有细菌。
[主播] 然后完了就买很多包的盐，一包一包，一包一包，一包一包在里头撒。
[嘉宾] 没有了。
[主播] 没有了是吧？
[主播] 5000单的盐。
[主播] 因为这个盐盐很便宜嘛，是吧？
[主播] 那你要不再给大家上5000单嘛？
[主播] 你让我把这个故事讲完。
[主播] 可以吗？
[主播] 我记得北方的冬天啊，天空很蓝，太阳显得很高。
[主播] 秋风很萧瑟，刮几次之后呢，叶子都掉地上了。
[主播] 我记得那个院子里，我们家以前院子有栽了好几个很高很大的桐树。
[主播] 每次温度很低的时候，刮上一场风，
[主播] 秋风里头那个桐树的叶子就晃晃悠悠的向下飘荡。
[主播] 跟蝴蝶一样在飘荡。
[主播] 那个就是饥肠辘辘的游子从学校回到家里之后呢，
[主播] 你看到了妈妈，
[主播] 不紧不慢的站在院子里。
[主播] 身上散着秋日的阳光。
[主播] 洗干净的那个菜的叶子，一片一片认真的叠放整齐。
[主播] 然后倒进去很多他晾凉的那个凉白开，再撒上一包一包的盐。
[主播] 那个过程充满了仪式感。
[主播] 因为它很麻烦。
[主播] 我们常常其实所说的仪式感就是麻烦。
[主播] 但凡吃饭之前让你先换个衣服，然后再让你去洗个澡，再点个香，然后再弹个音乐的，那就是仪式感。
[主播] 仪式感很多时候就是麻烦。
[主播] 因为你得费心思嘛。
[主播] 因为难得嘛。
[主播] 所以才珍贵。
[主播] 太容易的事情大家一般都不珍惜。
[主播] 每天都能见到董宇辉，你看这两天你就不想看了。
[嘉宾] 我前几天都看。
[主播] 所以我我会我以后应该减少出现的几率。
[主播] 你不想见我。
[嘉宾] 我不想见。
[主播] 听话，你说你不想见我。
[嘉宾] 我错了我错了。
[主播] 然后我一会儿把这回放发给俞老师，让我休息几天。
[主播] 实在想睡觉。
[嘉宾] 没有了。
[嘉宾] 要不给董老师搞个鸡蛋。
[主播] 鸡蛋可以。
[主播] 鸡蛋拿出来，大家拍鸡蛋，我继续给你讲这段啊。
[主播] 在北方的农村家庭里头，如果一个母亲的手艺好啊，她必须能做很多可口的饭菜。
[嘉宾] 一会再加1000单。
[主播] 1000单。
[主播] 只有1000单，自己去拍啊。
[嘉宾] DHA的鸡蛋。
[主播] 高DHA,两个就够一个青少年一天的DHA的需求了。
[主播] 北方的家庭里头，如果是巧手的母亲呢，她一定会做很多可口的饭菜。
[主播] 当然这里头还有一个非常重要的检验标准，就是每年在霜降的时候，她能不能腌好一缸的菜。
[主播] 那个大大的缸啊，
[主播] 里头叶子、盐、水混合在一起。
[主播] 摸着人手冰凉。
[主播] 每年都是那个那个那个日子。
[主播] 阳光清冷。
[主播] 树叶飘荡。
[主播] 妈妈瘦小的身子站在那个大大的缸面前。
[主播] 我到现在都记得那个画面，虽然我其实不太喜欢吃他腌的那些东西，因为我觉得它太咸了。
[主播] 我自己很挑食。
[主播] 我从小就是煮个粥，放个白糖。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 对，就是倒不是蛋，其实我挑食，从小都是那样子长大。
[主播] 我小时候不是很多东西，我以前跟你讲过不吃饺子吗？
[主播] 就是因为后来妈妈给我包饺子，才有那个自助那个学生那奶奶给我送送一次饺子。
[主播] 后来饺子在我心里成为一个特殊的食物。
[主播] 我小时候也不喜欢吃那个妈妈腌的那个菜。
[主播] 也坦诚来说，大家知道腌制的都对身体也不健康吗？尤其是腌的以前这种粗盐其实不健康。
[嘉宾] 大盐。
[主播] 后来我记得我在读书的时候，每年秋天想回一趟家。
[主播] 因为我记得秋天的时候你回到农村啊，那个小孩能吃的东西很多。
[主播] 长得又大又结实的南瓜。
[主播] 然后家里果园那支头这个晒着阳光，霜降之后叶子掉在地上，踩着沙沙作响，秋日里红色诱人的迎风飘荡的苹果。
[主播] 延伸出去的平原上，一颗颗柿子树，枝头的柿子挂的如红灯笼一样。
[主播] 那是北方的秋天。
[主播] 然后呢，有时候有那种耕牛或者是拖拉机在辽阔的土地上作响，然后新翻的泥土的清香，旁边正好是静静开放着的野菊花。
[主播] 你想象一下那样的画面。
[主播] 清冷。
[主播] 那种清冷的感觉，阳光又给你一点点的温热，就像你现在坐在你家里空调的风偶尔吹过你一样那样的舒服舒爽。
[主播] 年少时候想飘荡，想游四方。
[主播] 后来我记得我读大学的时候，每年一到秋天，我在西安，我就看着远方的山嘛。
[主播] 西安旁边就终南山嘛，大家听过终南山下活死人墓。
[主播] 神雕侠侣学籍江湖。
[主播] 我那时候看着终南山整个的叶子一天一天变黄。
[主播] 然后呢，可能几次雨，几次秋雨，几次秋风之后，叶子就落光。
[主播] 你看着那样漫山的黄叶后来落的光秃秃的时候，
[主播] 你就在想老家的院子里，
[主播] 清瘦的妈妈应该又站在那个大水缸前。
[主播] 不厌其烦的煮的凉白开的水。
[主播] 洗干净的叶子，一层一层的码放整齐，然后撒上一袋一袋的盐。
[主播] 他为了让那个过程又发酵，他必须得给上面压上一个很重的石头。
[主播] 以前人们生活条件不太好嘛，对吧？
[主播] 你可能你没有这样的经历啊，我相信有的人跟我有同样的经历的。
[主播] 那会儿有的学生，就像我姐姐上学那会儿家里真的很难，就经常还拿那种咸菜吃嘛。
[主播] 很难那会儿。
[主播] 嗯，每年我都能记得那些画面。
[主播] 然后妈妈就站在院子里，不厌其烦。
[主播] 一点一点的摆放整齐。
[嘉宾] 还有10单。
[主播] 只剩10单了是吧？
[主播] 你看我还没有卖的，鸡蛋的自己卖完了。
[主播] 后来呢，因为冬天大家也能买到菜了，因为大棚技术了。
[主播] 确实技术的进步给了我们更好的生活体验。
[主播] 我前几年还问我妈妈，我说妈，你为什么现在不不弄那个咸菜了？
[主播] 妈妈说现在都没有人吃咸菜了。
[主播] 现在大家冬天都可以买到菜了都。
[主播] 我说我还是挺想让你弄咸菜的。
[主播] 我就随口那么说了一下，前年吧，前年还是大前年。
[主播] 结果过年回家的时候有一天，反正过年大家应该都吃得比较好嘛，对吗？妈妈恨不得把所有的大鱼大肉都给你攒了那几天一次吃个够。
[主播] 哇，突然给我端上一盘咸菜。
[主播] 我说你为什么突然端个咸菜呢？
[主播] 妈妈说不是你要的吗？
[主播] 其实我随口说一句，我没有往心里去，我只是随口说而已。
[主播] 结果他真上的端一盘咸菜。
[嘉宾] 鸡蛋没有了。
[主播] 把胡萝卜切成了丝，把青椒切成了丝。
[主播] 还有切的那些包菜的叶子切成丝。
[主播] 拌的还香。
[嘉宾] 董老师别报鸡蛋了，没有了。
[主播] 没有了是吧？
[主播] 不能讲了是吧？好，行。
[嘉宾] 腰果，腰果。
[嘉宾] 再上点小零食。
[主播] 我不知道有多少朋友跟我有同样的那种经历啊。
[主播] 还是挺美好的。
[主播] 我特别怀念家乡。
[主播] 怀念秋天的北方。
[主播] 怀念一望无际的平原上拖拉机的轰鸣作响。
[主播] 新翻的泥土散发出清香。
[主播] 少年在飘荡。
[主播] 你想象你你你把这些画面连起来，你再想象一下。
[主播] 父母在村里劳作，然后呢孩子在县城的操场里。
[主播] 刚到学校九月都是大扫除嘛。
[主播] 其实一般农村种地都在十月多，十一以后了都。
[嘉宾] 错。
[主播] 对，已经那时候才才天气冷。
[主播] 就像极了，那种感觉就像极了九月，大家刚打扫完这个大扫除，拔完草以后九月新学期的操场那种感觉。
[主播] 非常有画面感。
[主播] 我后来每年一到秋天，我就特别想回那种辽阔的北方。
[主播] 我想去看农村的景象。
[主播] 我想去看红通通的柿子。
[主播] 我想跟爸妈去去这个挖这个自己家种的那个地瓜红薯。
[主播] 我想跟他一样去。
[嘉宾] 要吃腰果吗？
[主播] 对，腰果，对对对。
[嘉宾] 马上没腰果了。
[主播] 我想跟他去这个摘南瓜。
[主播] 妈妈每年种的那个南瓜特别大。
[嘉宾] 南瓜我给你有。
[主播] 有南瓜是吗？
[嘉宾] 这个是小南瓜。
[主播] 不影响不影响。
[主播] 这个口感其实更好。
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 对，这个口感其实更好，坦诚来说，这个口感更好。
[主播] 其实我我今天早上在讲，我很庆幸小时候有这种农村的生活经历。
[主播] 我前天讲这个一场冰雹之后，当时家里的苹果绝收了，奶奶捡苹果那一段。
[主播] 今天在各个社交媒体上流传特别广。
[主播] 你知道在农业耕种里头，每一份收获真的来之不易。
[主播] 钱挣得很难。
[主播] 粮食也收的很难。
[主播] 挣钱怎么说呢？就这个单词叫earn。
[主播] 很难叫hard。
[主播] 连起来有个说法叫hard earned。
[主播] 就是来之不易的。
[主播] So money was hard earned and all the crops were hard earned.
[主播] 因为你知道农业耕种里头真的有时候太难了。
[主播] 任何的懒惰在农业的劳作面前，任何的懒惰是致命的。
[主播] 在天灾面前，任何的抱怨也是无用的。
[主播] 所以长期从事农业劳作的人，最后都有几个特点。
[主播] 想到家乡。
[主播] 想到新翻泥土清香。
[主播] 想到在你家地头的草丛里头。
[主播] 深秋的菊花。
[主播] 极其的勤奋。
[主播] 开的黄亮亮。
[主播] 懒就得饿肚子。
[主播] 我当时听妈妈说那可以用来装枕头，我还拔了好多晒干的装枕头。
[主播] 他又极其的坦然。
[主播] 因为天灾是经常发生的事情。
[主播] 很有意思。
[主播] 没有办法避免。
[嘉宾] 很香。
[主播] 你不可能在一场暴雨之后站在地里去哭爹骂娘。
[主播] 有朋友说有车子收到烂了是不是？那个烂了你直接联系客服啊。
[主播] 在我们直播间里只要买到的任何问题，有问题大家请联系我们就行。
[主播] 没有意义其实。
[主播] 你只能赶快想办法再看家里还有哪片地，还能种点东西，让孩子赶快吃饱肚子。
[嘉宾] 包赔。
[主播] 坏果包赔啊。
[嘉宾] 坏多少赔多少。
[主播] 坏一半全赔。
[主播] 请放心，因为这个快递确实。
[主播] 所以这个我我觉得其实这种农业耕种的这种经历，对于很多的农村孩子来说，其实是一种命运的馈赠。
[主播] 有的快递如果说路。
[主播] 我我我我深深的以此为豪。
[主播] 我说是命运的馈赠，其实是非常理性的说，我觉得我没有胡说。
[主播] 它晚了几天，在那块多停了，或者是摔了那种碰了。
[主播] 就是因为他能够给我从小养成很多的好习惯，他能够让我有比较正确的价值观。
[主播] 有可能冰袋烂了，或者是。
[主播] 确实可能会有。
[主播] 当然在商业社会里头，有时候甚至显得你是慢的，你是愚蠢的。
[主播] 就是大家知道直播带货很少有人愿意做农业。
[主播] 你总得未雨绸缪，你总得提前考虑到未来可能出现的灾害。
[主播] 因为坦诚来说这是个脏活累活。
[嘉宾] 脏活累活。
[主播] 你得囤粮食。
[主播] 这真是个脏活累活。
[主播] 你得慢慢吃。
[主播] 你说你卖一单土豆你能挣多少钱？
[主播] 挣不了钱。
[主播] 但是你要知道在互联网经济里头，大家就是看到了一个热的风口的时候，立刻把所有的投资砸进去，立刻追求规模，急速增长，讲一个资本神话。
[主播] 呃，卖个红薯，南瓜你能挣多少钱？出击农产品，它又不需要加工，就没有什么利润。然后你卖个水果呢，万一路上冰袋一化一颗碰，就会出现收获问题。所以其实卖农产品是脏活累活。卖得多，挣钱挣得少。这个过程还比较漫长，但是难的东西也得有人做呀，你说呢？大家都去跳容易的事情做，那也没有意义的，对吧？感谢大家啊。有朋友说今天早上在央视看到我了。连续三个频道，明天好像农业频道，应该是央视七套的应该，明天要来，明天采访。其实他们并不是说就是不是说我很重要啊，其实是大家都希望我们去关注农业，关注农村，关注农民，关注农产品。因为我刚描绘了一个非常美好的北方的乡村的画面，听起来有一种田园牧歌的感觉，很浪漫，你想到桃园名。但同时你其实更应该想到的就是那些人可能辛苦劳作，然后呢万一有个这个一场冰雹，你家的苹果绝收了，奶奶就跪在泥地里头把那些苹果全部捡起来，还要拉回去的样子，对吧？就想到了其实爸妈可能劳累了一年，他其实有时候这个粮食，嗯。所以我们要更多去关注他们嘛，他有著自己别样的美，当然他也有著这个美背后的一些不容易，我相信你能理解得了啊。来我们现在给大家带来下一个东西。还有什么？腰果卖完了是吧？
[主播] 这其实是商业逻辑，对吗？
[主播] 商业要求的是快。
[主播] 但是如果你是种地，你你就清楚的知道苹果就是三四月份开花，十月才收。
[嘉宾] 南瓜。
[主播] 南瓜还有。
[嘉宾] 还有1500单。
[主播] 南瓜。
[主播] 他没有办法快。
[主播] 你你要知道这个庄稼种进去，拔苗助长，你把拔死了。
[主播] 学过吧？
[主播] 苏东坡传今天有吗？苏东坡传没有了是吧？
[主播] 农业耕种的人有一个特点，就是他得遵循自然的规律。
[嘉宾] 没有了。
[主播] 我们这两天在直播间里把苏东坡传卖了十几万本，然后全国好像现在都找不到库存了。
[主播] 他得有耐心。
[主播] 所以我常说耐心是智慧，而且更多时候它是一种克制。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 这个有个切开的给大家看一下啊。
[主播] 它是一种珍惜。
[嘉宾] 腰果我们加了2000单在二号链接。
[主播] 因为刚说了嘛，hard earned。
[主播] 你怎么能浪费？你怎么能挥霍呢？
[主播] 腰果加了2000单，想要的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 那对于粮食你没有办法浪费，没有办法挥霍，你对于家里的那些物件，你也常常缝缝补补。
[主播] 有朋友说明天要上班，但是我喜欢看董会在这擦桌子。
[主播] 惜时用用。
[主播] 喜欢看董会擦桌子。
[主播] 所以人们总是显得很念旧。
[主播] 你不要为难自己。
[主播] 到了晚上呢，放下手机，出去跑一跑步。
[主播] 所以后来人对于感情好像也是如此。
[主播] 啊，见一见朋友。
[主播] 对吗？
[主播] 人对于身边爱的人呢，也常常是如此。
[主播] 然后呢，看一本书，聊一聊天，吹一吹夜风。
[主播] 我就特别喜欢那种感觉。
[主播] 人间那么美好。
[主播] 你觉得呢？
[嘉宾] 我们腰果只有1000单了。
[主播] 像我我都是想有那些自由经常没有。
[嘉宾] 一号链接。
[主播] 感谢大家，感谢大家，我讲了北方的农村，最终卖出去了腰果。
[主播] 如果我有那样比较清闲的生活，我会很开了。
[嘉宾] 拉回现实。
[嘉宾] 怡然自乐。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 南瓜还有1000单。
[主播] 虽然这俩之间没有任何关系，但是我觉得我描述这些画面是共同唤醒的人们内心关于美的理解和欣赏。
[主播] 有朋友说我们家就是种南瓜的，我在你直播间买了一单南瓜。
[主播] 前两天我看那个说我们家就是做海产品的，我在你家买了四箱箱，被媳妇打了一顿去。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 美可以是你去西班牙，在巴塞罗那的海边，地中海边，海浪吹来，你吃了一盘那个那个海鲜饭。
[主播] 还有武昌的朋友买了武昌大米。
[主播] 笑死了。
[嘉宾] 感谢大家支持。
[主播] 没必要啊，没必要，我真觉得没必要。
[主播] 你可以在这聊天也行，跟我们听我们说话也行。
[主播] 你你你们家都是做这个，你买这干啥？
[主播] 你觉得呢？
[主播] 理性消费啊。
[主播] 我我觉得没必要。
[主播] 我觉得没必要我就不让你买。
[主播] 反正对吧？
[主播] 买不买是你的自由，但是我觉得。
[主播] 没必要啊。
[主播] 你家都是种南瓜，你再买。
[主播] 当然这个贝贝南瓜可能跟大家平常家里种的不一样，我们种的平常种是种大的，这种贝贝南瓜就是切开之后，你把这个子一掏，然后切成小脚，蒸一下八分钟左右，特别好吃。
[主播] 很细腻，板栗的口感。
[主播] 糯糯的。
[主播] 我我一年，我以前每年到了秋天就能吃到这个。
[主播] 糯糯的南瓜。
[主播] 还有弟弟刨的那个红薯。
[主播] 他们在一起炖一下，还有土豆，你知道吗？三种都是很黏很糯的东西，炖在一起，很香其实。
[主播] 可能由相同生活经相似生活经历的人就懂。
[主播] 夹生的米，煮着野兔和那个虾，墨鱼。
[主播] 对，这就是我们所说的大家想大河和三三四季。
[主播] 然后你也可以是去澳大利亚，买了一个巨大的澳龙。
[主播] 那个澳龙花了好多钱。
[主播] 就是我们所说的人间烟火和直断清长啊。
[主播] 你也可以去温哥华，你在UBC的海滩下，看见虎鲸跃出水面。
[主播] 你你有没有发现时常描述那样的场景会让人感觉放松和愉悦？
[主播] 你后来会去很多地方，那你仍然会在每年你秋天想到北方。
[主播] 发现没？
[嘉宾] 是放松和愉悦。
[嘉宾] 想到老家。
[主播] 对，就是它其实并不美好。
[嘉宾] 想到我们直播间的腰果。
[主播] 想到直播间的腰果，对。
[主播] 你要真的在那里住一住，你发现贫穷。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 蚊子。
[嘉宾] 我俩进入梦乡，你怎么样？
[主播] 蚊子。然后呢，没有你喜欢那种城市的东红酒绿。
[主播] 我俩进入梦乡，你怎么样？
[嘉宾] 快点把钱搞好。
[主播] 讨厌。
[嘉宾] 把钱搞好。
[嘉宾] 交通不发达。
[主播] 想要啥都没有。
[主播] 想到新翻泥土的清香。
[主播] 你又见过新翻的泥土吗？
[主播] 确实。
[主播] 它没有我所描述的那么美好，如果那不是生你养你的地方的话，其实它没有那么美好。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 它真的是一股清香的。
[主播] 但哪怕你在这里想像一下，对吧？
[嘉宾] 那会儿反校不都操场上每人去划地吗？
[主播] 我们哪怕夜公后龙呢？
[主播] 对。
[主播] 你至少得到一种心情上的愉悦，可总可以吧？
[主播] 把它扒起来。
[主播] 爸妈就在那里翻地。
[主播] 啊，我好希望龙好希望龙东西会来，吓一跳，赶快走。
[主播] 也可以，也可以对吧？
[主播] 然后又又用一个那个工具把那个拉平，然后再给里头弄种子。
[主播] 你不用真的喜欢那些地方，但你至少能够给你产生这种心情愉悦也行啊。
[主播] 你觉得呢？
[嘉宾] 对对对。
[主播] 然后我就趴在旁边的那个树上，摘那个那个柿子。
[主播] 有朋友说这个故乡容下肉身，城市容下灵魂。
[主播] 确实如此。
[主播] 小时候全是那样的画面。
[嘉宾] 还有300单。
[主播] 长大之后就没有这样的，我我我我如果以后有孩子，我一定带孩子在农村住上几年。
[主播] 还有300单啊。
[嘉宾] 二号链接。
[主播] 有朋友想要我身上的这个衣服是吧？
[主播] 这个好像我们在定制。
[嘉宾] 已经在路上了。
[主播] 好的话我们给大家说啊。
[主播] 有朋友说董老师请把眼睛睁开。
[主播] 你这不是强人所难。
[嘉宾] 难上加难。
[主播] 你把屏幕搓大，你能看这条缝隙。
[主播] 那个缝隙就是万物皆有裂痕啊，那是光照进来的地方。
[主播] 有缝隙呢。
[嘉宾] 没有了。
[主播] 没有了是吧？
[主播] 又拿两个，那两个是活的吗？
[主播] 为啥？
[主播] 是品牌商又送了是吧？
[主播] 今天可别把他动死了。
[嘉宾] 这是放在冰块里。
[主播] 别把他动死了。
[嘉宾] 放在一号里啊。
[嘉宾] 上。
[主播] 昨天昨天还有人问。
[主播] 两只。
[主播] 保活。
[主播] 不是顿龙虾。
[主播] 298。
[主播] 一斤，一只是一斤还是一只是两斤？
[主播] 一定要让他住几年。
[嘉宾] 一只一斤。
[主播] 这个价格其实还是。
[主播] 我相信他的人生经历会更加的丰富一些。
[主播] 还是比较便宜的。
[主播] 他就知道在秋天那段时间要吃曲儿。
[主播] 因为大家如果去你们平常买的那个生鲜的地方，你你现在去看一斤的价格应该是。
[主播] 去叫声非常的清脆。
[嘉宾] 前段时间100多。
[嘉宾] 270吧。
[主播] 非常的清脆。
[主播] 270吧。
[嘉宾] 雨后的泥土也有清香。
[主播] 可以便宜20块钱是吧？
[主播] 是。
[主播] 我可以把它这个脚套粘了吗？
[嘉宾] 我觉我我我我我。
[主播] 但是我也给大家科普一个另外一个知识，很煞风景的是农业劳作所占的碳二氧化碳排放量可以占到20%左右。
[主播] 试一下。
[嘉宾] 你跟他这冰壳吗？
[主播] 看他会不会夹我。
[嘉宾] 会夹。
[主播] 这个也是加拿大海域的那个吗？
[嘉宾] 是的，加拿大的波龙。
[主播] 这个是比尔盖茨写的气候变化与人类经济，哎，这本书能找到，我问一下。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 波龙。
[主播] 我会把他勒疼了。
[嘉宾] 帮我去找。
[主播] 比尔盖茨的。
[主播] 这样他是不是就不疼了？
[嘉宾] 也喝。
[嘉宾] 聊聊。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 对，这本书。
[嘉宾] 也喝。
[嘉宾] 现在就聊。
[主播] 他很友好的伸出了他的手。
[主播] 他提到农业耕种里头，农业里头的主要碳排放第一个就是牛羊和猪，他们放屁的。
[主播] 你好。
[主播] 你看你看，他跟我握手，你好。
[嘉宾] 小兄弟。
[嘉宾] 放屁。
[主播] 小兄弟。
[主播] 放屁非常严重，甲烷嘛。
[嘉宾] 一个夹二两。
[嘉宾] 他夹二两。
[主播] 第二个其实就是翻泥土的时候，其实会把泥土里头的很多的温室气体翻翻出来，确实会有，嗯。
[主播] 你知道他的合的力很大，但是他往外伸的力不大，你知道吗？就像狗的嘴一样，他咬合力很强。
[主播] 但你用手从外面握著他，他张不开了。
[主播] 但是主要不是这些啊。
[主播] 那种地种多少年了，以前也没有啊。
[主播] 这是一个bug,你能理解吗？
[主播] 其实主要还是因为工业的发展，发电机这些。
[主播] 他的身体是有设计的，缺陷的。
[主播] 想要的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 啊，钢筋水泥啊这些。
[主播] Yeah, this is called lobster.
[主播] Lobster.
[主播] 高碳排放的东西。
[主播] 这种就比较大了。
[主播] 小那种叫 crayfish或者 crawfish,这种叫 lobster。
[主播] 所以我不知道大家有没有同样的感觉得，可能你你如果城市长大，你可能跟我不会有共感啊，对不起，我啰啰嗦嗦讲了一段自己的这个童年经历。
[主播] Lobster。
[主播] 就比较大嘛。
[主播] It's basically huge.
[主播] Lobster, then the crayfish or crawfish.
[主播] 它也可以叫 crayfish,或者叫 crawfish,两种说法都听过啊。
[主播] Crayfish或者 crawfish就是大家晚上在夜摊上吃的，那种。
[主播] 那种小龙虾。
[主播] 这个是大的叫 lobster。
[主播] 南瓜还能在上一波吗？
[主播] 南瓜你看还有没？
[嘉宾] 没有了。
[主播] 没有了是吧？
[嘉宾] 挖不过来了。
[主播] 这倒不是挖不过来，是收不过来的。
[主播] 大家能理解，你要做农产品，或者你家在农村种地。
[主播] 你就能理解一个一个非常真实的事情就是你得克制自己的欲望。
[主播] 我今年想20万单南瓜。
[主播] 南瓜办不到呀，你别为难他。
[嘉宾] 帮我。
[主播] 他不是一个工业制造品，随时想要多少就有多少。
[嘉宾] 现在楼下还有。
[嘉宾] 腰果没有了。
[主播] 现在楼下还有。
[主播] 腰果也没有了。
[主播] 今天孙前说让我把那个吃了呢。
[嘉宾] 感谢大家，感谢大家。
[嘉宾] 去哪了？
[嘉宾] 放生了呢。
[主播] 所以我特别喜欢看到了南瓜呀，土豆啊，红薯呀，这一类的东西。
[主播] 那个都动死了。
[嘉宾] 想吃吗？
[嘉宾] 打个打说不了了。
[主播] 两只。
[主播] 因为我每当想到这类东西，就想到了秋天。
[主播] 看下它的爪子。
[主播] 想到北方。
[主播] 想要的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 想到家乡。
[嘉宾] 这多少？
[主播] 想到想到新翻泥土清香。
[主播] 没有多少了是吧？
[嘉宾] 昨天被你也是卖空了。
[主播] 想到在你家地头的草丛里头深秋的菊花。
[主播] 昨天被我卖空了。
[主播] 我还有这特异功能。
[主播] 大家不知道以前在在我火之前，我在我们直播间里。
[主播] 是卖货最差的一个。
[主播] 因为没有之一啊，没有之一。
[主播] 我很有自知之明，没有之一。
[主播] 我一站到镜头前就胡扯。
[主播] 什么苏格拉底，伯拉图。
[主播] 每次导演就很著急，董会你能不能卖个货？
[主播] 然后呢，东西早都卖完了，或者早都没有库存了，我还在这扯，还没有扯完，还让我把那段发挥完，好为人师嘛，毛病啊，这都是毛病。
[主播] 导演就提醒，董会能不能过下一个。
[主播] 每次都是这样子的。
[主播] 但这两天人多了，反而大家好像更加包容我了。
[主播] 有朋友说为什么这两天卖的都一样，因为这两天农产品只要一上立马卖空，现在没有什么农产品这个季节能这么大量的供应。
[主播] 然后书呢，前两天买的好点书，现在全国库存也都卖空了，现在没让卖的。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 当然可能还有更多其他的好书，因为我还没有读过，因为我读书有限。
[主播] 我我过几天需要去再读一些书，然后过来再给大家继续分享。
[主播] 感谢大家啊。
[主播] 午餐肉。
[主播] 梅林小黑猪火腿午餐肉罐头。
[主播] 我们之前给大家卖的是这个云南宣字的，大家为什么最近没有宣字的？因为卖空了。
[嘉宾] 卖空了。
[主播] 卖没了。
[主播] 就连云南宣字他们现在生产也跟不上我们的销售速度了。
[主播] 还是很开心的，我觉得把一个农产品能够推荐给这么多的人。
[主播] 其实我是很开心很自豪的。
[主播] 火腿午餐肉。
[主播] 大家知道把黑猪的后腿。
[主播] 挂在山洞里头抹上盐。
[主播] 那是盐的味道，那是山洞里头穿堂而过风的味道。
[主播] 那是时光沉淀之后岁月累积的味道。
[主播] 你单单就是想像一下那样的味道，它都充满了神秘感。
[主播] 都令人期待。
[主播] 在我刚说的在农业耕种里头耐心是一种智慧。
[主播] 你不能期待今天种明天就要熟。
[主播] 那我觉得火腿就是这样一种充满了浪漫感的食物，因为你挂在那头会挂很久。
[主播] 如果直播间里有很多南方的朋友，家里经常挂那种辣肉对吧？
[主播] 有的能挂挂一年多的，甚至时间更久那种肉。
[主播] 体现人们对食物对生活的一种克制。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 我能不能一对一顿炫完？
[主播] 其实也可以。
[主播] 也可以。
[主播] 但你炫完了以后以后拿什么炫呢？
[主播] 所以没有办法。
[主播] 它只能是控制著去吃，想吃的时候，逢年过节的时候吃一些。
[主播] 跟其他的菜炖一锅，让家人改善一次生活，吃点荤腥。
[主播] 对吧，以前其实那种原因。
[主播] 但是现在的我们已经能够随时想吃就能吃到了。
[主播] 但是我觉得火腿这种食物仍然充满了那种美感。
[主播] 就是一种克制的浪漫，然后一种岁月的沉淀。
[主播] 风、盐、阳光和时间。
[主播] 把诸多的魔法混合在一起，给你很棒的味觉体验。
[主播] 梅林小黑猪火腿午餐肉罐头。
[主播] 大概就是那种感觉吧。
[主播] 我可能描述的不是太准确。
[主播] 我相信你吃完之后可能会有更好的感受的，嗯。
[主播] 呃，火腿不仅在我们这有，其实在西班牙也有。
[主播] 我们有一年去巴塞罗那的时候就吃过。
[主播] 然后，哇，他怎么了？
[主播] What happened?
[嘉宾] 又急了。
[嘉宾] 二号链接。
[主播] 他伸出大手，捏了一个叶。
[主播] 我你。
[嘉宾] 他肚子疼。
[主播] 你看。
[嘉宾] 赶快给他下去看医生。
[主播] 他吐了。
[主播] 刚是不是晕车了？
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 他被你给讲晕了。
[主播] 没事吧？
[主播] 我不说了，对不起，我不说了，我不说了。
[嘉宾] 快送下去，快送下去。
[主播] 我不说了，你别生气，别生气，哥，哥别生气。
[嘉宾] 来了来了。
[主播] 别生气，对不起，对不起。
[嘉宾] 他还有100单啊。
[主播] 对不起，对不起，你别生气，别生气。
[主播] 气性这么大，别生气。
[嘉宾] 大家收到都是保活的哦，也不是活蹦乱跳的。
[主播] 大家收到是保活的啊。
[主播] 问一下供应商那个怎么能活，让他继续活著，好吗？
[主播] 要不然。
[主播] 死掉很可惜的。
[主播] 我不知道家里有爸有有有孩子的家长能理解。
[主播] 本来是菜市场买了一条鱼，活著要宰杀的，结果孩子那么可怜，吃它干啥？
[主播] 就哭著硬不让杀，孩子出门去玩了一圈，回来把他杀了。
[主播] 孩子吃的时候边哭边吃，吃完的时候妈妈给我再咬一碗。
[主播] 小时候我们家就是呢。
[嘉宾] 我小时候。
[主播] 小时候家养的是黑猪。
[主播] 这个也是梅林小黑猪。
[嘉宾] 小花。
[主播] 黑猪其实是我们的传统土猪，大家所知道的这个。
[主播] 现在吃的白猪基本都是英国或者美国的进口猪种。
[主播] 所以小猪佩奇应该是白猪。
[嘉宾] 白猪。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 但是猪八戒肯定是黑猪。
[嘉宾] 黑猪。
[主播] 肯定是黑猪，因为那会我们当地的这个猪就是黑猪。
[主播] 黑猪的特点是生长速度特别慢，一般都是养一年左右，到过年腊月才宰杀。
[主播] 我记得以前小时候，他是我的好伙伴。
[主播] 我放学回来小学的时候，那会无忧无虑，给他去割草。
[主播] 喂。
[主播] 还有去果园里偷偷摘一些苹果回来给他吃。
[主播] 他吃的很开心，我也看得很开心。
[主播] 小时候我妈现在描述，儿子我看你吃饭就跟你看猪吃饭一样。
[主播] 很热闹，很有食欲。
[嘉宾] 苹果也有。
[主播] 苹果也有，给大家。
[主播] 三号链接。
[主播] 然后呢，过年要宰杀那个猪的时候，我哭得很难过，爸能不能我们留下他？
[主播] 他是我的好朋友，爸说可以。
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 结果我爸说你跟朋友出去玩去。
[主播] 骗子，男人都不可信。
[主播] 把我骗出去，结果回来把我朋友杀了。
[主播] 哭得很伤心，很大声。
[主播] 然后肉煮出来的时候，我说爸你给我多成一点。
[嘉宾] 大家笑。
[主播] 吃的很香。
[主播] 对不起，对不起，我对不起我的朋友，但是它真好吃。
[主播] 黑猪的特点就是生长时间长。
[主播] 所以相对口感会肉会更更硬一些。
[主播] 然后脂肪其实也更厚。
[主播] 但是就是因为脂肪厚所以香啊，大家知道蛋白质是没有香味的。
[主播] 香都是脂肪的味道。
[主播] 然后因为生长时间长，它确实也更好吃一些，嗯。
[主播] 想要的朋友自己去拍啊。
[嘉宾] 还有1000单。
[主播] 刚有朋友说龙虾被我说吐了。
[嘉宾] 是真的。
[主播] 他真的吐了。
[主播] 在这呆著呆著，吐了一点黑色的汁液，然后开始肚子疼。
[主播] 还好我没有动，全程我没有动它，咱就回放了。
[主播] 还想饿我。
[主播] 我只是讲了一下中国的北方。
[主播] 他估计是想家了。
[主播] 我们要把它放生了吧。
[嘉宾] 昨天就放，今天还放。
[主播] 对，放了吧，不吃了，我不吃了。
[主播] 他是我的好朋友。
[主播] 我说我还想吐了。
[主播] 所以我说时间久了，你都会厌烦我的。
[主播] 一开始看星星看月亮的时候，管人家叫小甜甜。
[主播] 后来新人胜旧人，管人家叫牛夫人。
[主播] 你都会厌倦的。
[主播] 等你厌倦我的时候。
[主播] 你就不来看我了。
[主播] 那会网上有人骂董会的时候，你还会点赞。
[主播] 现在有人骂董会，你还替我反驳呢。
[主播] 想自己去拍啊。
[主播] 金字塔原理。
[主播] 这套书非常的经典。
[主播] 也是我们在新东方当老师这些年，几乎应该每个人都读过的一套书。
[主播] 呃，其实这两天我尽量在这给大家推荐一些文学类的书，哲学类的书，历史类的书，人物传记这些。
[主播] 其实我读的书更多的是关于管理的。
[主播] 但是在孙老师，在我们公司CEO的反馈里头，董会非常努力。
[主播] 结果越努力呢，这个破坏性越强。
[主播] 因为智商很低，所以非常拼。
[主播] 本来想著勤能捕捉，结果发现越努力破坏性越强。
[主播] 然后呢，让团队的朋友们都非常的辛苦，结果也没什么进步。
[主播] 所以我现在都不这样了，我现在伤自尊了。
[主播] 像读过的管理书类其实更多，但我现在不敢讲，因为不自信了。
[主播] 但是文学类的书啊，哲学类的书啊和历史类的书，对吧？
[主播] 它没有办法实践啊。
[主播] 没有办法实践，你怎么知道我读的不对，你怎么知道我说的不好呢？
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 没有比较，没有参考，无法验验证我的错误呀，对吧？
[主播] 科学的本质是可以证伪的。
[主播] 那没有办法证伪。
[主播] 我说的理解就是我的理解。
[主播] 所以我现在已经选了一个安全区域，虽然还是会被导演骂。
[主播] 但是我已经选了安全区域了，嗯。
[主播] 这个想要的朋友们自己去拍啊。
[主播] 刚进入直播间的朋友，请大家点击左上方关注我们，这里是于敏红老师带队。
[主播] 新东方转型给大家推荐好物的平台叫做东方真选。
[主播] 我我当然我们公司这个文化氛围也比较的开放。
[主播] 我也经常黑我们这个孙老师。
[主播] 我说这个非常感动我们的老板工作的那么的努力。
[主播] 其实有时候想一想他也可以歇一歇。
[主播] 这么多年以来，要不是他这么努力。
[主播] 可能我们早都。
[主播] 感动，我们的老板工作那么努力。
[主播] 其实有时候想一想，他也可以歇一歇。
[主播] 这么多年来，要不是他这么努力，可能我们早都成功了。
[嘉宾] 现在很好吗？
[主播] 我以前也这样说。
[主播] 感谢领导的帮助。
[主播] 领导要不帮忙，我早都进步了。
[主播] 领导要不努力，我们早都成功了。
[主播] 大概就是那种意思。
[主播] 想要的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 我特别害怕我在镜头前让大家觉得不舒服，所以如果你对我有任何的批评意见也可以说，可以说啊。
[主播] 可以说。
[主播] 若批评不自由，则赞美无意义啊。
[主播] 人必须得清醒。
[主播] 人得实事求是。
[主播] 什么叫实事求是？
[主播] 没有完美的人。
[主播] 所以在别人骂你的时候，挨骂也要立正，挨打也要立正。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 你能承受得住别人的批评，
[主播] 你才有资格去听别人的赞美。
[主播] 必须的。
[主播] 咱现在要卖这个吗？
[主播] 这个冷静去拍啊。
[主播] 因为这个它是有图案版，有的插画可能画出来那种魔法的，比较风格可能有的孩子会吓到。
[主播] 但是你像这这种就还行。
[主播] 猫头鹰啊，火车啊，这种就还行。
[主播] 但有的页面，比如说颜色用比较深的话，害怕孩子会害怕。
[主播] 完全看孩子啊。
[嘉宾] 2000套。
[主播] 这个这个完全看大家，好吧，这个我就不强烈推荐了啊。
[主播] 有的书我是可以强烈推荐的，但这套书就算了。
[主播] 因为确实我昨天翻了一页，我发现它用的颜色可能让孩子看起来有点害怕。
[主播] 有朋友说可以讲一讲你老婆吗？
[主播] 可以啊。
[主播] 对，有朋友说让我讲一讲我老婆吗？
[嘉宾] 嗯？
[主播] 很年轻。
[嘉宾] 已经这样了。
[主播] 有一种知性的美。
[主播] 热爱生活。
[主播] 在六月的清晨打扫干净房子，
[主播] 拉开窗帘。
[主播] 阳光洒进来。
[主播] 他在桌子上会放一束花。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 他会在周末跟我一起爬山。
[主播] 看湖水。
[主播] 感受山林间，
[主播] 清爽的风。
[主播] 他热爱美丽。
[主播] 会在夏天穿漂亮的裙子。
[主播] 在秋天跟我一起去摘银杏树的叶子，做成书签。
[主播] 夹在书里。
[主播] 他会买很多诗人写的诗集，挑出最喜欢的那一篇。
[主播] 把干的银杏书签全部塞在里头。
[嘉宾] 感觉像像。
[主播] 他说，
[主播] 他说生命的幸运。
[主播] 行了，我编不下去了。
[主播] 对不起，我真的我真的编不下去了。
[嘉宾] 编不下去了。
[主播] 敢死说，有朋友说这个卖菜的还马自己给骗睡著了。
[主播] 编不下去了。
[嘉宾] 这是理论派。
[嘉宾] 对，不是实践派。
[主播] 他说，
[主播] 爱上我是这一生最幸运的事情。
[嘉宾] 牵手。
[主播] 他还说，总有一回如果，
[主播] 既然你下班早的话，咱去老地方吃饭。
[嘉宾] Wow。
[主播] 可以啊。
[主播] 哪？
[主播] 老地方吗？
[嘉宾] 老地方。
[主播] 哪啊？
[主播] 老地方。
[主播] 不是你说清楚老地方是哪啊？
[主播] 后来闹钟就响了。
[嘉宾] 梦就醒了。
[主播] 后半部分确实没有听全。
[主播] 但凡闹钟晚个五分钟，我兴许都知道今天去哪里找他了。
[主播] 别骂了，别骂了。
[主播] 有朋友骂渣男。
[嘉宾] 我给你讲的。
[嘉宾] 故事。
[主播] 我们都希望遇上一个这样的女子。
[主播] 但我们想要遇见好的人的前提是希望自己要
[主播] 自行。
[主播] 呃，
[主播] 进步很重要。
[主播] 你不能一味的只是要求要求他。
[主播] 自己从来不读书，不学习。
[主播] 懒惰。
[主播] 脾气暴躁。
[主播] 就是上了个班回家就躺在沙发上。
[主播] 双腿叉开。
[主播] 一直刷手机。
[主播] 那不对的。
[主播] 你知道好是会互相影响的吗？
[主播] 你知道差其实也是互相影响的。
[主播] 你从来不克服自己，不修炼自己，却要求他成为你喜欢的模样。
[主播] 你挺过分的。
[主播] 你觉得呢？
[嘉宾] 没错。
[主播] 想要的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 有朋友说老鱼在聊天是吧？
[主播] 老鱼后来喜欢聊天。
[主播] 让他聊。
[主播] 没事。
[主播] 老板要多聊一聊。
[主播] 聊一聊心情好。
[主播] 他烦心事挺多的，让他开心一点，挺好的。
[主播] 来，我们继续。
[主播] 下一个是啊。
[嘉宾] 鲍鱼。
[主播] 咱现在就卖这种东西了吗？
[主播] 活的。
[嘉宾] 活的鲍鱼。
[主播] 为啥不能做一个让人吃一吃呢？
[主播] 这个如果你们家附近能够买到直接买活的，那也行。
[主播] 如果你们家不太方便的话，你可以在我们这买。
[主播] 什么价格，导演？
[主播] 这还挺大的。
[嘉宾] 89十只。
[嘉宾] 15820只。
[主播] 哇，这个是真活的。
[主播] 还真的挺大的，看到没？
[主播] 保活吗这个？
[嘉宾] 保活。
[主播] 保活啊。
[主播] 保活。
[主播] 他还在动，你看。
[主播] 看到没？
[主播] 确实挺大的。
[主播] 这个品质确实好。
[主播] 一分价钱一分货啊。
[主播] 这个是不是就不拆开了？
[嘉宾] 不拆了。
[主播] 不拆了啊。
[主播] 这样他能活几天啊？
[嘉宾] 这种真空的话，基本上你回家就没什么问题。
[主播] OK,明白。
[嘉宾] 水里，然后再盐。
[主播] 然后等他把脏东西吐出来。
[嘉宾] 就是这个东西你肯定要刷一下。
[主播] 刷一下。
[主播] 然后把它的那个吃的那个绿的那个夹出来。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 然后切成小块。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[主播] 然后炖点小米粥。
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 切一点点小的生姜末。
[主播] 把它放进去。
[主播] 好朋友，你就这样对他的。
[主播] 男人果然都不能相信。
[嘉宾] 鲍鱼得放点辣椒。
[主播] 点击屏幕中间，加入抖音的东方真选会员。
[主播] 我们里头有券，可以用来买我们自己的东西啊。
[嘉宾] 5块20的。
[主播] 有一张5块，还有一张20的啊。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 鲍鱼有1万单是吧？
[主播] 终于有一些能卖的东西了。
[嘉宾] 贵点。
[主播] 小时候记得一篇课文叫我的叔叔于勒。
[主播] 学过吧？
[主播] 但那个不是鲍鱼啊，它是那个Oyster,就是牡蛎或者生蚝。
[主播] 我们后来去西班牙的时候，在这个海鲜市场吃过。
[主播] 地中海捞的还是活的。
[主播] 给你起开。
[主播] 很灵活的起开。
[主播] 然后滑两下，把里头的海水倒出来，捏一个柠檬，直接喝下去。
[主播] 但不建议。
[主播] 有的海域的确实不能喝，不能直接吃。
[主播] 有的地方可以。
[主播] 它也分具体的品种。
[主播] 想要的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 之前我刚刚已经教给你怎么吃了。
[主播] 炖点小米粥。
[主播] 然后呢，应该是先要用热水把它煮一下。
[主播] 然后这样它就变硬了。
[主播] 然后呢再切成小丁，放在粥里头慢慢炖一下。
[主播] 切一点点生姜末。
[主播] 口感会非常好。
[嘉宾] 再点点辣椒。
[主播] 然后呢，
[主播] 烫个秋葵。
[主播] 菜心。
[主播] 挺健康的，挺舒服的。
[主播] 我自己会做菜你知道吗？
[主播] 奶奶，你知道我会做菜吗？
[嘉宾] 反正我没吃过。
[主播] 你知道我刚毕业那几年啊，那会特别穷嘛。
[主播] 那会跟另外两个同事合租。
[主播] 还是俩女同事合租。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[主播] 但她们俩不会做菜，但她们俩饭量都很大。
[主播] 真的。
[嘉宾] 你们在看吗？
[主播] 然后她们俩应该不在看。
[主播] 她们俩有自己的生活。
[主播] 然后我们当时下班回去呢，就会买一些菜。
[主播] 轮流著买，但一般都是我做。
[主播] 炒菜。
[主播] 我说各种拔丝红薯这样的东西我都会。
[主播] 这难度级别挺高的吧？
[主播] 先炸，炸完的时候这烧那个糖稀，等起沫的时候，一定得起沫，然后赶紧倒下去，然后就翻炒。
[嘉宾] 我一个东北人。
[主播] 对，然后就好了。
[主播] 拔丝红薯。
[嘉宾] 炒菜。
[主播] 什么水煮牛肉。
[主播] 然后呢，就基本上你能想到的菜我大部分都会做。
[嘉宾] 怎么说？
[嘉宾] 什么时候老师？
[主播] 可以。
[主播] 改天我能买得起房子了，你做。
[嘉宾] 吃。
[主播] 你家啊。
[主播] 可以可以。
[主播] 改天让你尝一尝我给你炖的这个小米粥。
[主播] 然后拿这个煮一下，热水焯一下，出来把上面一清理。
[主播] 洗刷干净，切成小块。
[嘉宾] 好，那我就开单了。
[主播] 可以可以。
[主播] 你拍吧，改天我给你试一次。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 不会做菜的英语老师，
[主播] 不是个好哲学家呀。
[主播] 鲁迅说的。
[主播] 不信你问他去。
[嘉宾] 没说过。
[主播] 别听说，没听说过是吧？
[主播] 多新鲜的啊。
[主播] 想吃朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 有朋友一直说麻烦这个老师睁开眼睛说话。
[主播] 咱能给朋友们发点什么好福利不？
[主播] 给他们点实惠，他们就不这样为难我了。
[主播] 我真的办不到，求你了。
[嘉宾] 加会员给优惠券啊。
[主播] 求你了，我真的办不到。
[嘉宾] 加20减50块。
[主播] 加会员。
[主播] 这个能用吗？
[嘉宾] 不能。
[嘉宾] 自由。
[主播] 明白。
[主播] 有朋友说说笑话会不会自己不笑？
[主播] 会啊。
[主播] 很多笑话说著说著自己都不笑了。
[嘉宾] 想要别人笑。
[主播] 有一个电影，小时候大家看的时候应该都是在笑。
[主播] 长大了之后看就开始哭了。
[主播] 我特别喜欢。
[主播] 我高中那会呢，跟非主流一样。
[主播] 我当时觉得自己要探索人生的意义。
[主播] 你觉得一个男生生命中某个阶段应该是有主题的。
[主播] 比如说勇敢。
[主播] 比如说自我。
[主播] 比如说超越。
[主播] 比如说抉择。
[主播] 我在高一那一年里头结实了几个自己当时觉得的好朋友。
[主播] 每天跟著他们去网吧里上通宵。
[主播] 我也不会。
[主播] 现在来看就是挺蠢的。
[主播] 挺蠢的。
[主播] 因为我知道现在屏幕前有很多的孩子们在看，很多妈妈现在就拉著孩子玩，或者不要写作业，听东西会直播。
[主播] 放过孩子啊。
[主播] 挺辛苦的，让他睡觉吧。
[主播] 挺蠢的，孩子们。
[主播] 我当时浪费了自己特别好的年华。
[主播] 后来在网吧里这个实在没事干。
[主播] 去看那个大话西游。
[主播] 我能一年能把那电影看真的500遍都不止。
[主播] 你知道一天晚上就三遍。
[主播] 哎，我爸妈这会在不在？
[主播] 我爸妈知道我高一上通宵还打的。
[主播] 然后呢，一开始就哈哈哈哈笑笑笑。
[主播] 前几十遍都能笑出来。
[主播] 中间慢慢就沉默了。
[主播] 沉默沉默著后来再看就哭了。
[主播] 那个就是人生中的很多遗憾。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 然后呢，我后来去过那个西部影视城一共去过五次。
[主播] 你知道每次去宁夏的时候啊，如果你在正确的季节去，他们家那个西瓜非常好。
[主播] 他们那块的西瓜非常好。
[主播] 就那种沙瓤的瓜，啪，摔地上。
[主播] 直接拿起来吃。
[主播] 还有这个哈密瓜。
[主播] 等今年这个七八月份，于老师再带我去那里直播上一次，帮助当地的瓜农去卖。
[主播] 如果有机会，我们到时候见啊。
[嘉宾] 来，让我们鲍鱼下去休息一会啊。
[主播] 让鲍鱼休息一会。
[主播] 鲍鱼工作很长时间，累了。
[嘉宾] 导演。
[主播] 他累了。
[嘉宾] 鲍鱼休息。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 然后呢，
[嘉宾] 鲍鱼生气了。
[嘉宾] 别说了。
[主播] 鲍鱼请我讲一个故事了，是吧？
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 好吃了。
[主播] 好吃。
[嘉宾] 我们山东的瓜。
[主播] 山东的瓜是吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 感谢你，感谢你。
[主播] 等等真贴心。
[主播] 等女朋友应该很幸福。
[主播] 然后我说过我是一个很贪心的人吗？
[主播] 我要去宁夏的时候，我就一路听那个大话西游那个一生所爱。
[主播] 我就连续。
[主播] 咱能放一生所爱吗？
[嘉宾] 当然。
[主播] 放一个，谢谢。
[主播] 你知道一路从西安开过去，因为有隧道，得八个多小时。
[主播] 比如说。
[主播] 至少啊。
[主播] 连续八小时听一首歌，很多人听到最后都怒了都。
[主播] 还好我是一个脑子反应慢，后知后觉的人。
[主播] 等你真正站在西部影视城，看著那个土墙上面那两个塑料人像的时候，你脑子里仍然是那首歌，虽然那首歌早都停了。
[主播] 我瞬间就想到了很多年前在那里拍戏的时候，站在城墙上那个。
[主播] 哈密瓜错了最后。
[主播] 我确定时候我就坐在那个。
[主播] 瞬间让你眼睛、耳朵感官得到刺激的事情。
[主播] 从那些中选取。
[嘉宾] 那你换吧，换吧，换吧。
[嘉宾] 他没有故事。
[主播] 现年轻人太浮躁了。
[主播] 不够厚重。
[嘉宾] 没拔过紫金宝剑。
[主播] 真真是，一看你就没拔过紫金宝剑。
[主播] 从来都没有命中注定过，怪不得你听不进这样的歌。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 超甜的。
[主播] 像初恋一样，超甜的。
[嘉宾] 我给你套一个西麦。
[主播] 没事没事。
[嘉宾] 水牛奶。
[嘉宾] 西麦和水牛奶，二号三号链接。
[主播] 早餐很方便啊，各位的乡亲们。
[主播] 不是这个呀。
[嘉宾] 我给你拿。
[主播] 好好好。
[主播] 西麦。
[嘉宾] 麦片。
[主播] Oat milk。
[嘉宾] 水牛奶。
[嘉宾] 然后三号链接。
[主播] Buffalo milk。
[主播] 在三号链接。
[主播] 咱连样品都没有。
[嘉宾] 刚才之后一个被套了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 水牛奶浓郁。
[主播] 唇齿留香。
[主播] 如流动的冰淇淋一般。
[主播] 回味微微带甜。
[主播] 恰逢盛夏时期遇见的鲜衣怒马的少年啊。
[嘉宾] 牛奶在二号链接啊。
[主播] 不好起吗？
[主播] 真的是那种感觉。
[主播] 回味无穷啊。
[主播] 喝一遍就难忘了。
[主播] 有朋友说终于终于会不插嘴了。
[主播] 我这是个职业病。
[主播] 你看我长的这个奇奇怪怪的，但是我有一点点的洁癖。
[主播] 可能因为成长过程中自卑，要么不自信，所以总想收拾干净一些。
[主播] 看起来体体面面落落大方。
[主播] 后来发现其实收拾的干净不会让你落落大方，后来其实是生活让你受的苦和读的你那点书让你与天落落大方了。
[主播] 咱现在卖啥？
[嘉宾] 西麦。
[主播] 对，麦片，我拿的手上，我骑到驴上问驴在哪。
[主播] 麦片。
[主播] 早餐吃啊。
[主播] 34块9。
[主播] 三问的呢。
[主播] 其实燕麦和优麦是同一种东西，你知道吧？
[主播] 中国北方也重了，大面积的重了。
[主播] 朋友说我们现在卖啥？
[主播] 小黄车里自己找，需要啥买啥。
[嘉宾] 都已经开价了。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 比如说今天去相亲了是吧？
[主播] 相咋样？
[主播] 有朋友说这个评价一下自己的眼睛。
[主播] 我这个眼睛呢叫若隐若现。
[主播] 可有可无。
[主播] 主要起一个点缀的作用。
[主播] 我的眼睛呢。
[主播] 像月初时候天上挂的月亮。
[主播] 又细又弯。
[主播] 因此才具有独特的美感。
[主播] 这个世界从来不缺少美。
[主播] 是缺少发现美的眼睛。
[主播] 你看我这样风清云淡的。
[主播] 镇定自若的。
[主播] 煞有其事的讲完这番话之后，你瞬间是不是现在就觉得我的眼睛看起来顺眼了一些。
[主播] 这就是文字的力量。
[主播] 男人的嘴，骗人的鬼。
[主播] 千万不敢信。
[主播] 黑的说是白的。
[主播] 错的说是对的。
[主播] 但他有一件事情说的很对。
[主播] 他说你很美。
[主播] 每一个天使都热爱美丽。
[主播] 所以他才懂得你珍贵。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 他说你很美。
[主播] 每一个天使都热爱美丽。
[主播] 所以他才懂得你珍贵。
[主播] 按时吃饭。
[主播] 按时睡觉。
[主播] 有朋友懂你，会这个脸是暴力丑学。
[主播] 钱难挣啊，为了挣这点钱。
[主播] 被人凌辱，消费。
[主播] 别这样说，我妈会难过，我妈会难过的。你们这样一直叫我方老师。
[主播] 我妈很生很生气，很难过，在群里说，我儿子哪方了？
[主播] 他出完之后，他觉得有点不真实，除了脸有点方。
[主播] 除了头有点方。
[主播] 除了下巴有点方。
[主播] 除了鼻子和门牙有点方。
[主播] 他还有哪方？算了，你要不撤回吧，你方言之后这更尴尬了，你是真是在安慰我吗？
[主播] 没看出来啊。
[主播] 反向操作。
[主播] 我叫董宇辉啊。
[主播] 再逃兵马俑。
[主播] 中关村周杰伦。
[主播] 曾用名中关村吴彦祖。
[主播] 一名叫董宇辉。
[主播] 今天还讲书吗？
[主播] 想听什么书？
[主播] 朋友说有洁癖还用擦，这是不同的纸。
[主播] 需要朋友自己去看啊。
[其他] 牛奶还有300单啊。
[主播] 牛奶还有300单是吧？
[主播] 看大家都喜欢我讲书呀。
[主播] 这两天尴尬的是，我想卖的书现在全国都找不到库存。
[主播] 你敢信？
[主播] 机会来了，没抓住呀，没书。直播间里现在45万人。
[主播] 没书卖。
[主播] 咱今天晚上有咱书，给我卖一点点呢。
[其他] 有。
[主播] 《额古纳河右岸》，来来来来，这样的好书多卖一些。
[主播] 还便宜。
[主播] 生命的丰富在于
[主播] 你把那个也拿来。
[主播] 生命的丰富在于同样的时间里头比别人经历得多。
[主播] 人生没有白走的路。
[主播] 每一步都算数。
[主播] 比如说你熬得更多的夜，受得更多的委屈。
[主播] 算。
[主播] 你吃得更多的苦，得到更多的掌声，也算。
[主播] 还有一种体验就是去更多的地方，看更丰富的风景。
[主播] 体会不同的人的人生。
[主播] 这个当然更算。
[主播] 《额古纳河右岸》，迟子建老师的作品。
[主播] 相当经典，而且这本书便宜呀。
[主播] 这个今天有多少万册导演？
[其他] 10万。
[主播] 10万册，全部上。
[主播] 不要给大家弄那种那种没意思的东西啊。
[主播] 鄂温克族和鄂伦春族
[主播] 的生活为原型。
[主播] 大兴安岭深处。
[主播] 游牧民族。
[主播] 你看完之后才发现竟然有坠落人间的仙境。
[主播] 我看完之后我非常羡慕，眼红啊。
[主播] 我甚至想以后能够经历这样的生活。
[主播] 当然我因为我在农村生活过，我知道文学作品所表达出来的美跟现实体验之间还是有很大的实际差异的。
[主播] 但我仍然对此充满了向往。
[主播] 大兴安岭的原始森林里。
[主播] 逐苔藓而居。
[主播] 充满灵性的驯鹿，当然在我们的语言里叫四不像，四不像白人就说得没有美感了。
[主播] 驯鹿。
[主播] 身上细腻的这个它的皮毛。
[主播] 和温柔的颜色。
[主播] 鄂温克人的习惯里头。
[主播] 出门会带着火种，在这本书里啊。
[主播] 不断地在山林里迁徙。
[主播] 他们对于自然的理解显得克制
[主播] 而尊重。
[主播] 当苔藓吃光的时候，会前往下一片地方。
[主播] 有经验的酋长
[主播] 会带领族人寻找下片适合栖息的地方。
[主播] 像是候鸟，偶尔驻足，但最终还是要飞向远方。
[主播] 还是要飞向远方。
[主播] 你们想听什么音乐？
[主播] 导演说上换个音乐。
[主播] 大家说上换个音乐。
[主播] 快。
[其他] 换什么？
[主播] 满足大家的愿望。
[其他] 一生所爱。
[主播] 一生所爱，是吧？
[主播] 可以。
[主播] 或者你换朴树呢？
[其他] 朴树。
[主播] 朴树那个。
[其他] 平凡之路。
[主播] 也可以，也可以。
[主播] 可以吗？放个朴树可以吗，朋友们？
[主播] 可以不？
[主播] 放完了这个再给大家放《一生所爱》。
[主播] 可以吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 哎呀，我一听这首歌我就想出发了。
[主播] 上什么班？
[主播] 不行，我老于还在呢。
[主播] 我后来读过很多书。
[主播] 我觉得我们注定要走向远方。
[主播] 我觉得我们基因里注定着要流浪。
[主播] 我身处异乡的朋友们啊。
[主播] 我素未谋面的亲人啊。
[主播] 我尚在未来的爱人啊。
[主播] 我们要一起携手走向远方。
[主播] 走向远方。
[主播] 我曾看过大张大河。
[主播] 感受过星辰湖泊。
[主播] 我曾看过大兴安岭的原始森林。
[主播] 和皑皑白雪。
[主播] 我知道在每年的春天冰雪融化。
[主播] 汇聚成河。
[主播] 我们要逐驯鹿而居。
[主播] 带上族人与火种。
[主播] 奔向远方。
[主播] 感谢大家啊，想看自己去拍。
[主播] 我读到这本书里头哪些场景开始感动了我。
[主播] 就是因为我没有经历过。
[主播] 所以我特别喜欢。
[主播] 当然你要换一个角度，那就是就是落后与愚昧。
[主播] 但你要以一种尊重和欣赏的角度去看，他们在族人遇到生命危险的时候，穿着彩色的衣服，闪着亮光的萨满。
[主播] 充满力量的祈舞。
[主播] 月光下人们架起篝火。
[主播] 饮酒。
[主播] 吃肉。
[主播] 畅谈到天亮。
[主播] 平静流淌的河流。
[主播] 偶尔飞起的各种鸟类。
[主播] 出没在河边的，大型动物。
[主播] 都是这本书给我带来独特的精神旅行。
[主播] 我看完之后就是一个强烈的，难以抑制的，无法磨灭的愿望。
[主播] 我要去大兴安岭。
[主播] 我要去更高的地方。
[主播] 人生时常会，在恍惚之间感觉，好像这个地方很熟悉。
[主播] 好像这个场景很熟悉。
[主播] 仿佛这个画面很熟悉。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 大概就是那种感觉。
[主播] 你有没有经常看到一个场景感，哎呀，我绝对见过这个东西，我绝对感受过这个地方，我绝对看过这个人。
[主播] 就有一种莫名的熟悉感。
[主播] 我也有理由相信在恍惚瞬间里头那种熟悉的感觉。
[主播] 是我们的先辈们曾经踏过的地方。
[主播] 它变成了一一点点微弱的记忆片段，藏在了你的记忆里。
[主播] 于无人的夜里，从睡梦中惊醒。
[主播] 回忆起你终将走向远方。
[主播] 想看的朋友自己去看啊，我觉得这本书特别好，充满美感。
[主播] 这本书是前段时间我在家里面没事，一下午看完。
[主播] 一下午一直看到晚上其实，看书速度比较慢。
[主播] 然后完了没事，我那两天就给集中在一块，24小时联播那几天。
[主播] 就给大家说大概十天前吧，联播了一晚上。
[主播] 第二天睡醒，头晕乎乎的。
[主播] 没事干，坐在那个院子里，那个鸽子飞起。
[主播] 再看了一遍，真美，越看越美。
[主播] 好像这里头爱情都简单，生活也快乐，人们知足常乐。
[主播] 与大自然和睦相处。
[主播] 就是我们理想中完美的样子。
[主播] 好，我们是货榜第一名。
[其他] 哎，哎，不能说。
[主播] 不能说是吧？
[主播] 啊，这不能说啊，我突然反应过来，因为咱好像前面没没卖啥东西了。
[其他] 没有，我们点点关注吧。
[主播] 点点关注，来来来，各位直播间的朋友们，请大家点点关注啊。
[主播] 孩子啊。
[主播] 有朋友说想要其他的音乐，你换一个其他的音乐啊。
[主播] 对，刚才那首是因为我我想听，所以我让导演换了一下，如果你你不喜欢的话，我先让导演换一下吧，不好意思啊。
[主播] 一生所爱，是吧？
[主播] 可以啊。
[主播] 《一生所爱》放完了，你可以给大家放那个，有朋友想听那个李健老师的《抚琴的散文诗》。
[主播] 可以。
[主播] 可以听，可以听。
[主播] 你要啥都行，只要你快点，别生气，气啥气？
[主播] 气出病来谁如意？
[主播] 别气。
[主播] 人生有那么多事情要烦心。
[主播] 守住快乐多难呀。
[主播] 所以更应该快乐。
[主播] 不卖大米，大米没了现在。
[主播] 现在没米了。
[主播] 朋友说如果方老师不划水，GMV会更高一些。
[主播] 我狠努力在卖货，真的，你出来吗？
[主播] 我狠努力的其实。
[主播] 我不想语速很快，然后一直用吵闹的音乐刺激你。
[主播] 因为那种时候你你就会有快速要做决定，你知道人在漫长的进化过程中其实有种习惯，当周围给你不安全感的时候，你要么就立刻做决定，要么是冲突，还是逃离。
[主播] 能理解吗？
[主播] 这是你漫长进化过程中的一个人的基本反应。
[主播] 然后让你有不安全感的有几个方式呢？第一个，吵闹的音乐，因为人在草丛里周围很吵闹的音乐的时候，往往就意味着可能有危险临近。
[主播] 第二个，我特别快的语速，让你大脑来不及反应。
[主播] 我也看过一些不好的书，书里头会给我这样讲过。
[主播] 那个时候你可能就快速决策，你就很快就买了。
[主播] 但我又不想让你那样，你觉得呢？
[主播] 我不想让你那样啊。
[主播] 你想自己买就买，不想买别买也行，好吧？
[主播] 我不想让你那样。
[主播] 我不喜欢那样，所以我也想那样。
[主播] 有朋友说好多人在老头直播间告状。
[主播] 说我咋了？
[主播] 我狠努力的好吗？
[其他] 狠努力在卖什么呢？
[主播] 狠努力在卖书。
[主播] 我不知道大家有没有跟我同样的感觉啊，我真的时常看到很多景色的时候觉得
[主播] 一定在梦里见过。
[主播] 虽然我躺在自家那个破旧的，出租屋上，出租屋的床上，但是我的思想绝对飘向过远方，绝对飘向过远方。
[主播] 我觉得那些记忆里唤醒的应该是祖先们深藏在我脑海里的回忆。
[主播] 在一两个睡着的夜里，那些遥远的回忆突然会攻击我。
[主播] 它叫醒我。
[主播] 行万里路呀。
[主播] 地方去得多了，你发现一个人就变得很有深度。
[主播] 书读多了，一个人会变得周全且理性，而且充满感性。
[主播] 这两个要同时存在。
[主播] 想要啥？
[主播] 除了这首诗，除了这本书，咱现在还有啥书？
[其他] 余老师的书。
[其他] 哎呀，现在卖一稿书就好。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 哎对，我桌上有一本，今天晚上好像可以抽余老余老师亲笔签名的书。
[主播] 可以抽十本。
[主播] 有老余亲笔签名的，东东在我桌上，你取一下，然后过来给大家看一下。
[主播] 就老余那本书。
[主播] 导演帮我拿一下老余那本书。
[其他] 黄色的。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 有十本亲笔签名的。
[主播] 《在岁月中远行》。
[主播] 《乌合之众》有吗？《乌合之众》有，但是没，那个书没库存了，我们这两天直播间里头经常都是，只要有的书一上，然后瞬间卖光，卖光之后，然后就没库存了。
[其他] 我们把有库存的书都挂在前面十号链接。
[主播] 有库存的书全部在前十号链接，需要朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 有人在老余直播间说你不想干了，你想去大兴安岭。
[主播] 你看你这个说话就是一门艺术，你这非要说这我这你这年轻人没有工作。
[主播] 你应该跟余老师说，董宇辉想要去大兴安岭。
[其他] 卖余老师的书。
[主播] 他想换个环境工作。
[主播] 想在不同的风景里，触景生情，用不同的文字和别样的美感来介绍余老师这本《在岁月中远行》。
[主播] 是得远行。
[其他] 是得。
[主播] 我整天站在中关村这样的钢筋水泥的楼里头，我能有什么远行？
[主播] 我都不曾见过。
[主播] 我怎么能想到？
[主播] 我都没有想到怎么脱口而出。
[主播] 当我没有感受，没有灵感。